[Music]
the medicare annual enrollment period is
happening now through december 7th and
you may have some questions well
selecthealth who are sponsoring this
next segment we'll be live in studio
this thursday to answer those questions
here to tell us more is danielle jones
welcome to the show hey casey thank you
very much how are you great who is
select health someone's watching right
now tell us who select health is select
health is a not-for-profit health plan
and our mission is to help people live
the healthiest lives possible
and we're in an integrated health system
with um intermountain health care and we
have medicare advantage plans in idaho
nevada and utah now you and i were
talking before we started this segment
and i myself had a lot of questions
about medicare what can we expect on
thursday you guys have a full thank bank
of staff members answering questions yep
so our answer team will be here to help
um people who may have questions about
medicare it's complicated it can be
overwhelming
you you know often see multiple
commercials this time of year but we're
really here to help you we really want
you to call in thursday and have an
expert answer your questions for you and
that's what we're going to have your
experts that can any questions can be
thrown at them they have the answer they
have the answer we've seen it all i'm
sure there's a hard question to answer
i'll ask you anyway what what are some
of the the more common questions you
guys get asked i know you get asked a
lot what are some of the more common
questions you get asked
you know do you cover my prescription
drugs that's a very common question what
kind of extra benefits are in the plan
is their dental is their vision are
hearing aids covered
all of that should be reviewed every
single year and we recommend that even
if you are on a medicare plan that you
review your options every single year
during this time because for the most
part it covers 65 and over of course
there's some suggestions so how many
people that that are signing up are i
guess would say new 64 turning 65 versus
people that are you know in their 70s
and want to change plans mostly new
people coming to you guys yeah mostly
new people if you're turning 65 you have
a seven month window usually three
months before and three months after
your birthday as a qualifying period to
enroll in medicare so it's a good time
to really look at all your different
options what's important to you and a
plan and reach out and get that expert
opinion if you need some help so as they
open the segment i pointed out how the
open enrollment is now through december
7th
what takes place on december 8th that's
the cutoff and there's no turning back
after that for the most part but again
there can be unique situations and if
you have those we say you know take a
look at everything um you know call us
as well there is another period that
that starts if there's something that
happened but it just depends on your
unique situation how important is this
because to me this is very important you
guys going to be here on thursday you
the insider how important is this that
we have this phone bank you guys are
providing answering all the questions
how important is this really important
it's important to look at your option
every year things change every single
year so if you enrolled in a plan last
year something has most likely changed
in that plan so you really want to make
sure that you know what's happening and
that you've reached out and just asked
the questions that you have that's why
we're here and we're happy to help and
you have the experts coming on thursday
we're looking forward to it danielle
yeah us too thank you for joining us i
appreciate it thank you we'll see you
thursday thursday the live medicare
phone bank with us here channel 8 is
happening this thursday november 18th
from 3 to 7 p.m select health you can
call them now at
1-855-442-9940 or visit
selecthealth.org jillian